what is Josh Hutcherson known for I'm
known for making movies and now I'm a
meme I'm happy about that but I'm
excited to get back to being known for
movies as well how did Josh Hutcherson
become an actor I was a young boy uh The
Ripe young age of age of 9 years old I
got out a phone book which many of you
might not be familiar with I called an
agency in Cincinnati and said that I
wanted to be an actor and they were like
let's talk to your parents and I was
like well they're at work then my
parents were like this kid will not stop
and they got behind me and then we drove
to California stayed in the motel and uh
started making movies Josh Hutcherson
new movie yeah I have The Beekeeper
which is coming out now January 12th
this guy Derek that I play in beekeeper
is like completely unhinged he's a
crypto bro multi-billionaire privileged
if I may say so just kind of
getting to play something that out there
in Wild was uh was a lot of fun